how do you generate interest in your
company I got a great question from one
of my readers Danielle who reached out
to me on Twitter and we followed by
email she's in charge of brand
acquisition and a new company and
basically is representing companies
we're trying to get sports stars to
tweet out and share their messages about
the brand with their audience and one of
my bites how do I stand out how do I get
customers how do I reach out to these
brands and get them interested it's so
common because if you want success with
your business you need to get people
talking about you you need word of mouth
to work for you you need people
spreading your message and saying I want
to work with this person or saying you
need to go work with this company you
need that because on the marketing and
advertising the world's not going to
help you if you don't have word of mouth
behind you every successful entrepreneur
has had a word of mouth in their favor
helping them so you need to get people
talking about you if you want people to
talk about you you have to give them a
reason to talk about you you have to
have something special unique different
over the top that gives people a reason
to talk about you you have to be
remarkable worth making a remark about
so what is it that's so great about your
business that I want to talk about you
why should brands care so this isn't a
new model right I can reach out to
athletes on Twitter myself or through
social media it's not a new model that
exists you're not create a new paradigm
so what is so special about what you're
doing what is it that is so great that
people going to talk about it maybe you
represent certain athletes that are big
name items maybe you have a certain
process that works that that is proven
that nobody else can replicate or
nobody's done before maybe you've worked
on great campaigns and they've had huge
success and you can use that as case
studies what is it like what's so
special about your business because i
hate reaching out to companies and cold
calling them say hey I'm from XYZ
company I've got a great service for you
you should come on board cool call it
may work I've never had success with it
and I think its success is dropping and
dropping and dropping because people are
really busy they do
want to be interrupted and they don't
care about you right now right it's so
hard to reach somebody on the phone
these days you need to have a message
it's worth spreading and have people
find you and talk about you so what's
unique about this business there's
nothing in this email that says what's
so unique about your company so that's
your homework if you want if you want
people to come to you you want people to
find you you have to have something that
is worth spreading it's that simple so
what is that message practice it hone it
refine it get excited by it speak with
passion then if you're making a video
where you're creating a blog post you
create a newsletter people will share it
right look at what your company is
producing look at the blog post look at
the tweets look at the youtube videos
look at the facebook post whatever your
do in a market yourself look at the
content you're producing our people
sharing it because for most companies is
no because the content is boring because
the content is average is the content is
mediocre there's nothing special about
it and people are busy so if you want
them to take notice you have to create
something amazing something that only
you guys can make something that has
feeling something that has a personal
touch to it and then people will share
it and clients will find you and your
ideal clients will find you so take five
minutes look at all the stuff you're
putting out and find one thing that you
could do tomorrow to make this content
better to have a message that resonates
more strong with people to create
something that actually hides value and
help somebody in their life and send it
to me too i'll give you my feedback but
if you have an outstanding message if
you have something that you passionately
believe in that is making a difference
that is that is from the heart and is
meant to change somebody's life but
that's the kind of stuff you're creating
then you're going to start attracting
customers to you who are ideal who will
spend a lot of money with you who won't
ask as many questions who will refer
business to you and will be lifetime
customers as long as you keep doing a
great job to start to work on your
message belief
those are you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
always makes me want to do more and I
love to hear we have to think leave a
comment underneath let me know your
thoughts you have a question leave it
below I'll make a video response thank
you so much and I'll see you soon